[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
July 21st I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
for many people whose first choice of
travel typically is getting on a plane
they're turning to a mode of
transportation they might never have
considered before taking a bus wsj's
Ethan Steinberg joins me with more
so Ethan how popular has bus travel
become well broadly speaking ridership
on Intercity buses and motor coaches is
trending upward this year and in some
corners of the industry it's booming
compared to last year so Greyhound and
the discount bus service flixbus which
together they are jointly owned by this
company called Flix North America a
ridership on their lines were up 63
percent year-over-year this July 4th
weekend Greyhound is the largest
Intercity bus carrier in the United
States so any number like that holds a
lot of weight but it isn't just
Greyhound that's seeing significant
increases year over year I spoke to bus
Executives all over from the Concord
Coach Lines which is a regional carrier
in New England to the luxury bus service
Vaughn Lane which is in Texas and to
another one in Florida and they all say
that their numbers are trending upward
and approaching if not exceeding what
they were seeing in 2019 now overall the
industry is still recovering from the
pandemic so it's not entirely there yet
and now of course travel everywhere is
up so this isn't unique to buses but
where we're really seeing the difference
here with buses is on those holiday
weekends when airports tend to get
crowded and demand tends to mount when
Greyhound and Flix plus were up 63 July
4th weekend year over year TSA data
shows that air travel was up just 11 so
still significant but there is a huge
difference there and so that's kind of
where we see this bus rebound really
coming into play so in terms of the
substantial growth in bus travel and the
popularity of bus travel we're talking
more than just the Greyhound and mega
buses that we see in the highway but
we're also talking about kind of a
burgeoning sector of the bus industry
which is the luxury or high-end bus or
what the CEOs of those companies would
like to have you call it the Luxury
Motor Coach they're trying to get away
from the term bus because they see their
options as kind of similar to a first
class experience on a flight on those
buses they have attendance come around
and feed you snacks and meals like if
you you were on a plane and they have
extra neck pillows and extra phone
chargers this this whole luxury high-end
experience that you really don't usually
associate with bus travel so there's an
emphasis on Comfort absolutely yes and
there's an emphasis on comfort and the
experience overall not just getting from
point A to point B okay so why are
people switching to bus travel in these
large numbers people once they started
to experience or once they started to
travel again after the pandemic kind of
their first point of contact with the
travel industry was the airport and the
airlines according to analysts and
Industry experts that I spoke to a lot
of people are switching from Airlines
and air travel to bus travel at the
outset of their trips and not just as a
plan B when something goes wrong at the
airport that's one big reason right they
don't want to even have the potential
for their flights to get disrupted or
delayed but another big reason is also
for cost people often think about kind
of the Greyhounds and the Flix buses
where you could buy a ticket for let
less than a hundred dollars and go you
know far distance now in terms of
efficiency getting from point A to point
B how does bus travel measure up to
other modes of travel
depends on a long bus trip like cross
country you're going through multiple
States taking the bus it takes a lot
longer than taking the train sometimes
there are transfers and it could be
overnight or even as up to 24 hours or
something like that but for these short
trips for example from Austin to Houston
or Nashville to Charlotte taking the bus
can sometimes take the same amount of
time door-to-door as taking a plane
because you don't have to deal often
with going to the airport and going
through security and waiting on lines
and at the gate then leaving the airport
it's just much more of a direct
experience point to point now you
mentioned a moment ago about cost can
you go into that a bit more for us how
would a luxury bus ticket compare to an
airplane ticket so the people I spoke to
who took you know anything ranging from
a Greyhound to a luxury bus service said
they just booked directly with the
carrier because you don't have to do a
lot of Deal Searching when you're
booking a bus ticket compared to when
you're planning to fly and that's
because in most cases even the luxury
bus services flying is more expensive or
at least equal to taking the bus now
you've spoken to some people who've
switched from air travel to taking a bus
what was their experience like one
person I spoke to for example is 29
years old and he traveled from
Indianapolis all the way to Marietta
Georgia via bus and he was moving in
with his family and had 50 pounds of
luggage with him carrying practically
his whole life he told me and the trip
was supposed to be 14 hours with a
couple transfers but at the second
transfer going into the last leg of the
trip from Nashville to Marietta he got
off the bus along with everyone else and
he was told that the next bus was
supposed to come and pick him up would
be canceled and they couldn't get him on
another one for another 13 hours and
then he told me he didn't want to be
stuck in the middle of corn fields with
his luggage and his whole life packed on
him so instead he ordered an Uber and
cost him 250 dollars so wait he was in a
cornfield practically Lee so he was kind
of in the middle of nowhere he didn't
know anyone he didn't have a lot of
money on him he hadn't slept in about 24
hours he tells me and so obviously kind
of like we were talking about earlier
any type of disruption whether it's
cancellation or a delay that could
happen in an airport you could also see
that on the ground and on the road even
on the side of a highway now I also
spoke to a man he's 25 years old he
lives in Atlanta and does social media
for an ad agency he used to fly from
Atlanta to Nashville but in late may he
heard about Von Lane the luxury bus
service from a friend and just decided
to take that instead to save some money
and save himself from the airport Hassle
and he liked it so much that he took it
round trip three weeks in a row she said
you like just being able to show up five
minutes before departure hopping on the
bus and he just didn't have to deal with
kind of going through security or
waiting on long lines on kind of those
other hassles that are associated with
airport travel so overall it is a mixed
bag and your experience on the bus will
certainly depend on what line you take
and where you're going that's Wall
Street Journal reporter Ethan Steinberg
and that's it for your money briefing
this week our producer is Ariana asperu
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
zinsley I'm your host J.R Whalen thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
foreign